well it's a huge night for Democrats and
what could be a make-or-break moment for
many of their campaigns first up in our
2020 roundup instead of projecting
confidence Joe Biden's team is going
after the media Biden's camp claims the
reason for recent negative coverage
isn't because of his endless gaffes
instead they're blaming it on young
reporters who think 276 year old is
uncool Greggy left is he uncool no he's
got problems and the media is not doing
Joe any favor by treating him like a
Faberge egg so he's saying that they're
picking on him they're not they're doing
a reverse Trump they're taking the
spotlight away from him because at
certain times he just doesn't look
healthy he doesn't look right but
they're fattening him up like a prized
veal for Trump he's like sitting in a
tight cage because he's not working the
muscles and he's becoming slow succulent
and unprepared for the nights it's going
to be so bad it's so bad and they really
need to get him out of there because
it's not gonna look good in income any
year Jesse I think it gets bad press
because he's a bad candidate he's a
relic he's not a rock star he wears
aviators and was Barack's VP so what I
mean if I were a reporter covering these
people I wouldn't want to cover him I'd
rather cover boot edge I rather cover
Elizabeth Warren even bata won't work
yeah I mean the guy's a gaffe machine he
doesn't attract any crowds I just don't
see it and if you're complaining about
the press and you're a Democrat that's a
problem yeah because they're supposed to
on your side right I'm gonna take a
contrary view I think this is signs of
life from Team Biden who they are
basically finally attacking something in
the press starting to attack Elizabeth
Warren even if they're not doing it
directly the op-ed today from the former
governor of Pennsylvania former DNC
chair ed Rendell and calling Elizabeth
Warren a hypocrite but she's nice I mean
that's basically what it said I think
that shows that they're willing to do
some dirty work but they're gonna use
their surrogates to do it I think
there's a lot more of it to come what
about that Juan do you think Elizabeth
Warren's going to go after Joe Biden
tonight now that they're on the same
stage
no very different lanes push Biden left
I mean technically if she was going to
go after anybody should go after Bernie
Sanders because he's the right
yeah she's already beating Bernie
Sanders now it's like she's kind of
legal right so I think look I think the
dynamic tonight is everybody says Joe
Biden's in the lead they love to see him
take a fall a pratfall and and then be
able to take some of his vote but do I
think that Elizabeth Warren wants to be
the one that looks like you know
fingerprints on the victims back no
because then that would hurt her with
fellow Democrats big time so I don't
think she's going to do that in terms of
this thing with reporters and Biden look
reporters didn't think that Hillary
Clinton was hip they didn't think Donald
Trump was hip what was going to win so
guess what
tough luck reporters I mean you just go
out there and cover the story but I do
think that a lot of people are just like
especially reporters Oh Biden's not
exciting Biden's not Obama well one
thing that doesn't seem to work in this
new political age is being a phony so
Elizabeth Warren loves attacking the
wealthy but it turns out that she has no
problem taking their money she's also
very wealthy herself and now she's being
called out for the hypocrisy as Dana
pointed out turns out she took a bunch
of corporate cash in 2018 that she's
rolled over to help fund her current
campaign so Greg she's been on this kick
of I don't take corporate money I'm only
listening to the grassroots I just want
small donors but she's more than happy
to actually take a lot of corporate
money I just see every time I see her I
see Jiminy Cricket and I don't know why
I don't know why the problem is what she
is saying her entire idea of banning
fracking to taxing everybody tube to
sponsor a trillion dollar fantasy is not
going to prevent it apocalypse at all
it's actually going to speed up the
apocalypse because other countries are
going to fill the void who are less
compassionate about the earth and we are
who aren't going to listen to a 12 year
old climate activists and take their
marching orders from her once we step
off this world stage there are going to
be there's going to be Iran there's
going to be Russia Venezuela are all
gonna step in and they just the
environment is just another road bump on
the speed highway love
the Democrats in Detroit during the
first debate talked about banning cars
for the sake of the green new deal yeah
are they gonna talk about cracking
Frankie in Texas
I don't know I'm gonna go there well
it'll be interesting you asked if if
Warren is gonna push bite and left like
they're already left he said he was
going to end fossil fuels in ten years
basically in the in the since they had a
last debate one of the candidates that
will be up there Andrew Yang talked
about a possible man mandatory buyback
of your gas-guzzling vehicle right and
be replaced by electric vehicle I mean
they're already there and I don't think
it matters if they do it in Houston
anywhere because now it's all a national
campaign
well Andrew yang is supposedly gonna
have a little bit of fun tonight so
let's listen to what he's challenged
president Trump on it would be Donald
Trump because I would school him Donald
Trump oh my gosh you just be standing
there being like I'd be like score left
Jesse Trump or yang Yang looks like he's
got some game I saw him play a little
bit he was dunking on an eight-foot rim
which is fine decent handle and a nice
jump shot but you know all these things
are solved on the golf course
really that Bay and I think Trump had
smoked him well one president Trump is
actually controlling the candidates
tonight he's this campaign is going to
have a huge banner saying socialism
sucks essentially outside of the debate
who do you think wins that argument and
socialism well I don't think there's
anything that Democrats can do that
would prevent Donald Trump from calling
them socialist now that they are they
are not socialists but I if you want to
see what a socialist is these are people
I mean if you say Social Security
Medicare Medicaid of soldiers I think
you lose big time with American voters
but Trump this is just trolling this is
silliness and I hope the Democrats don't
pay attention David Axelrod had a piece
today in the New York Times saying don't
let Trump get away with this kind of
stuff this jujitsu use his energy too
late it's too late wide Trump has
effectively introduced a new kind of
campaigning he has introduced the
concept of the Harlem Globetrotters into
politics watch me come to town and
plaster the Washington Generals that's
what it's good it be now he's going to
go through this whole thing and wherever
the Democrats show up he's gonna have a
little war room I go what can we do to
mess with them and it's you can't go
back after this even if he loses people
are gonna be doing this way differently
yeah but people get tired of it oh it's
just getting started using this act for
now we saw it in 2016 and he doesn't
stack on when you're at the beach and
then you hear that noise and you look up
and you see the plane fly that about
dollar Coronas to good feelings there he
looks away from the show